mom
guys
okay
[Music]
[Music]
tell me about your fantasies honey
[Music]
hey
started to think you wouldn't show
shouldn't have
to be honest why not
normally only work with fixers clients
that avoid him tend to be bad news
i just care about my privacy [ __ ] me
it's you
it's me lizzy wizzy
sit please let's talk okay
so what's this about
i think you can guess i'm in trouble
mm-hmm what kind
[Music]
this
good question
been a rough year creative block can't
even say the last time i made anything
worth listening to
and to make things worse i fell in love
i'm so sorry
and why is that sooner or later love
alone let you down
guess it'll be sooner
so we talking a man a woman
oh [ __ ] these hands sometimes seems like
i just brushed something in
sparks fly
anyway a man his name's liam
liam northam been together a few months
but
i think he's cheating on me okay
why the suspicion ah it's so cliched
it's embarrassing whispered phone calls
in the bathroom
strange receipts secret meetings in the
middle of the night
any specific event come to mind
my mind that's
that's a touchy subject why
don't know each other well enough for
that v
you talk to him at all tell him to his
face
you're adorable
imagine this we're never alone not
really
always surrounded by assistance pr reps
makeup artists
i stopped smiling at him for one
millisecond it'll be all over
every scream shade in this town
understood
no you don't understand not until you've
lived it
millions of eyes trained on you
constantly it can be beautiful
and terrifying liam northam
no don't know tell me about him
40-ish sensitive guy who never wanted
for anything
you know the type heard they exist
how'd you meet
he's my manager
i know i know how it sounds i never
meant to
he's not even my type but but
your body can be chrome but the heart
never changes
it wants what it wants
so what's my role here what do you want
proof and then i'll end things for good
liam goes to riot all the time i think
he meets someone there
i want to know who you'll find out for
me
can count on me perfect
remember i want specifics details
recordings or pics if you can sure
keep it in mind good now go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
enjoying the weather average
temperatures this month in night city
have remained within
human safety levels
me
[Music]
foreign
hmm you look okay go in
looking for a guy name's liam liam
northam
you know where i could find him
no you can [ __ ] off merc i ain't talking
better rethink that or you'll regret it
one more word out of you and i'll scrap
you so bad even
trauma won't know your ass from your
elbow
delta now
not a problem
[Music]
[Music]
so
oh uh linda champagne to the vip room
stat
okay just let me give three their check
looking for liam liam northam
ah that one [ __ ] can't stand that gunk
bad dipper plus he's a jackass
output's even worse output huh
interesting anyway where's he at
you know i can't tell you that
can't huh but know what i can do
crush your skull like a can of nicola
think if you really want to say no use
that skull sponge while you still got it
in the vip room with some new output or
to champagne so it's a party
but um you didn't hear it from me yeah
sure
hey you
so
so
right let's see what's here
champagne nice surprise
um considered a token of my gratitude
i know you don't often agree to use the
relic but well you don't usually make an
engram of a living person either
ah come on arasaka has taken a keen
interest in lizzie's career
be ashamed if it ended prematurely a
backup copy seems to be the most
sensible solution
about that once you made the backup can
you
tweak it to remove undesirable traits
because lizzy ever since her conversion
she
she hasn't been herself i'm afraid
that's impossible
engram saved in the secure your soul
program
cannot be edited but how significant
would these edits be
significant sometimes
sometimes i don't even recognize her
other times
never mind let's have a drink to our
partnership
oh [ __ ] you heard what i just heard
right relic
they want to do her like they did me
not exactly they wiped you here they
just want to make a backup
a backup v we're talking about a person
not your vacay snaps guy didn't even ask
he's just going behind her back he's got
no right to do it
nobody has that right especially without
her
no one [ __ ] how do i even tell her
don't have to camera in there where
there's a cam there's footage
hello v what's up
got some intel on liam and
is it what i thought
no worse lizzy much much worse
what do you mean listen don't know the
deets
but liam he he wants your engram
wants to copy you what but
why he said he said he's afraid
for you and of you
no no i don't believe it you hear me
not a single word you're lying
got the data to prove it here listen for
yourself
no no it's
no [ __ ]
[Music]
what
[Music]
lizzy what in the [ __ ]
now i get the rush
v i i i was angry i i pushed him
these [ __ ] arms these hands
oh my god
you ever wake up in the middle of the
night
and not know who you were for a second
shreds or i mean
you ever feel like you weren't really
you
i that's how i feel all the time
every moment this emptiness this
helplessness i stopped seeing creating
just now i i just wanted to break up
with him you know
tell him i wanted him out of my life but
i i don't even know how
when i i
you strangled him lizzy slowly you
crushed his spine
i i was angry i must have lost control
guy got what he deserved
so this is about the body right that's
why you called
yes i the media can't hear about this
got it that would be
oh huh
the world would eat it up a tale of the
temptation to control another's memory
a grim reminder that a person is merely
a collection of bytes that can be
copied reproduced copied reproduced
lizzy snap the [ __ ] out of it what about
the body
i don't know do whatever take it
somewhere burn it
i'll pay you okay i'll take care of it
you sleep soundly now
sleep i won't sleep i don't need to
thank you liam you don't realize it but
you've given me something beautiful what
the hell are you talking about
govi go and take him with you
someone should give you a checkup see if
you're okay lizzy
someone you trust i like
what's happening to me lovely to meet
you b
now go go
uh
you